hi I'm sad Russell for reason TV we're
here today with Robert Scheer in our Los
Angeles studios over the last 50 years
very few people have been more powerful
or principled voices in American
journalism than Robert Scheer in the
1960s he was editor of ramparts magazine
a cutting edge magazine on the American
Left there's a longtime correspondent
and columnist for the Los Angeles Times
he's the author of nine books including
the great American stick-up how rig and
Republicans and Clinton Democrats
enriched Wall Street while mugging Main
Street he's also professor of
communications at USC Annenberg School
of Communications and he's the editor in
chief of the online news magazine truth
digg.com which is won several awards
thanks for joining us Bob I wanted to
ask you I've been following your career
quite closely for a number of years and
i have to say with some certainty that
there's no one on the Left who more
consistently praises libertarians than
you why is that why do you have such
nice things to say about libertarians
well let me start on a different tack
okay no I think you could have strong
views you can come to conclusions as I
have you know you can advocate certain
positions and still attempt to be fair
and objective I think it's possible to
do that and I deny the notion that it's
only people who are deliberately on
something called the center who are
capable of being objective changing
their position challenging themselves
and so forth and I've been associated
with positions that later I felt were
really wrong I made mistakes and my
first encounter I guess with
libertarians came in the city college
cafeteria and I'd all hear all about
Mises and Hayek and you know all this
stuff and I guess I ran and there were
alcoves it was the trotskyist alcove and
there was the if they were called
libertarians were you in such an alcohol
I didn't blow you love oh why there you
go to eat different things they have
different diets no and an hour she it
was a very lively atmosphere III loved
it and you know and people challenge
challenge and so forth and so I don't
know I never had the view that they were
libertarians are outside the reasonable
debate I think it and if my only concern
is if people call themselves libertarian
or consistent and so when ron paul or
rand paul those are the two libertarians
I've gotten in trouble with some somehow
on my Wikipedia page I'm a big supporter
of Rand Paul because I dared to suggest
he'd be preferable to the hack the
Democratic hack that he was running
against who didn't know it for anything
and I yes I've had kind things to say
about Ron and Rand Paul because they're
consistent on the question of the
Federal Reserve and crony capitalism
bailing out the banks you know I think
they're very good they're very good on
foreign policy generally a consistent
view on foreign policy belief in self
determination I think they're consistent
with the founders who did want to avoid
foreign entanglements and so forth I
still believe in public education
however I believe in Level II I believe
in leveling the playing field so you
know I just don't have some kind of
blind prejudice you know I wrote a
column today which I had some kind
things to say about John McCain you know
who I've criticized and pray so I think
it is possible to be a leftist
journalist and yet try to you know to be
objective and call it as you see it so
in the 1960s when you were editing
ramparts magazine you published Murray
Rothbard and Carl oglesby who were at
the time engaged in a project to bring
together the new left and the old what
they called the old right which became
known as libertarians they had limited
success in doing so but they did manage
to coalesce with people like students
for a Democratic Society around the war
and around civil liberties is that
possible today and what are the
potential problem I don't know I'm not a
good political organizer and not
at predicting you know who's going to
win and though I again at ramparts we
weren't a leftist publication we started
as a Catholic literary quarterly and we
were influenced by pope john we were
cared about the farm workers and Chavez
and I was the first non-catholic in the
door certainly the first Jew in the door
and it was never an ideological
publication I think the most
controversial thing I did it ramparts in
this regard is I had some kind things to
say about Ronald Reagan and I
interviewed Ronald Reagan when he was
running for governor and I said at that
time we had an editorial which I said
Pat Brown had exhausted his ideology or
his approach the whole big government
big spending and so forth which was
actually quite supportive favorable to
big business you know bring the highways
and the water in Southern California and
so forth and I thought that Ronald
Reagan did represent general terms of
you I wasn't going to embrace him I
certainly was disappointed about his
gassing students and am Berkeley and I
got guests myself you know so i have my
criticism reagan but and then when he
ran for president i ended up having a
lot of time with reagan I think more
than any of the journalists we got along
quite well so I don't know about
bringing them together what let's cut to
the chase what are the real issues okay
what's the problem i have with
libertarians all right i believe yes if
we lived in a world that jefferson was
describing and we were basically stay
cold and we were all white and male and
we had a steak some kind of farm and if
government were small you know and most
decisions were local not some big
federal and we avoided empire and
favored Republic was as to my mind the
main contradiction that yes I think
that's the ideal society and in that
society you wouldn't need much
government much of a role for government
we would pretty much start from an equal
place we would succeed by dint of our
work and our sweat we could comprehend
the
and yes I I think an ocean a very
severely limited government government
intrusion respect for the Fourth
Amendment which is being ignored now
even the right to bear arms if you know
how to use them and you're on your farm
all that would make sense we don't live
in that world we live in a world of
concentrated economic power of
incredible manipulation the Free Press
that they in trying anyone could have
one you could have the penny press you
put up a wall poster the Declaration of
Independence was a wall poster that you
could put it what we don't live in that
world I mean we live in a world of
concentrated wealth and manipulation and
so then you have to talk about making it
somewhat more equal in order for
democracy to have a chance and that's
really our our argument a few weeks ago
I heard you on the radio railing against
liberals in the Democratic Party who
were apologizing for NSA surveillance
and you in the same sentence I think
praised Rand Paul for taking the right
position on that what is it about
liberals and much of the left today that
makes them apologists for state power
well people do stupid things on all
points of the political spectrum right
and have stupid positions for instance
if you want to take the left and after I
was part of the lift that was critical
of Cold War liberalism and we had our
issues with Kennedy and and even with
Schlesinger Arthur Schlesinger and so
forth I think the stupidity on the left
that I was associated with was we were
for the davids against the Goliath and
some of those David's turned out to be
terrible and totalitarian and vicious
and maybe we were some of us not all of
us because there was a strong
anti-communist left it was a strong in
her left committed to individual freedom
and against any kind of totalitarian
impulse but I would say the errors of
the left pretty much had to do was okay
they're the underdog maybe they have to
organize that way until he can get
started I think in terms of the liberal
position what happened to liberals in
this country if they got freaked out by
McCarthyism they got co-opted by power
careerism trumped principle
surviving and let us take a cut cutting
issue the Cold War okay if you look back
into Cold War future stars there what
the hell was that about my great liberal
cause one thing up right there was a
construction near that any intelligent
person had two new was absurd no was
absurd right the International communist
conspiracy and his timetable for the
take over the world what there weren't
two communist countries in the world
that could get along with each other I
mean the sino-soviet dispute went back
to the 20s Tito broke away I mean you
just looked at the only communist they
got along with some communists were
conquered by other communist like in
Eastern Europe and they had to get along
and then the second they could get out
from under him they did it to the
construction that ideology was supreme
that there was some kind of text books
you could read and you know read Marx or
something and you could predict was all
nonsense and anyone who had a
rudimentary knowledge of the area would
know that no the Chinese and the
Russians even if they were reading some
similar texts weren't going to get along
it would it be shooting at each other
and the Vietnamese certainly we're not
going to go under their thumb because
they've been occupied by the Chinese for
that you can just go it was obvious on
the face as a young person I looked at
this and I said it is obvious on the
face I thought well I'll just point out
the error of their ways and they'll
realize that and they'll stop this war
in Vietnam right I went to Vietnam at an
early period as 1964 single I was
writing about our road another great
liberal project the Vietnam War yes but
it's not my project okay that's why
you're here I'm but I'm trying to I'm
trying to answer your question an honest
way I was operating under the illusion
that logic in fact mattered and that if
one could point out these things these
contradictions people would then say oh
yes of course we won't but no because in
fact careerism Trump's self-interest
Trump's fact and logic you know getting
along being in the establishment having
power and that continues today like my
last book was under banking meltdown
totally irrational what were these
collateralized debt obligations and
credit deposit they were if the Mafia
did it they'd all
in jail it was told scam anyone who
looked at it knew it was a scam I knew
it should be against the law was against
the law you know verging of all this and
everything and then these people got
along they changed the law they made all
this stuff you know there's stripped in
event of the most minimal a regulation
sold it as a certainty and we're off to
the races here so my view is ideology is
less important than integrity that's my
view and the reason I'm here is I think
there are plenty of libertarians that
have integrity so it's worth while
talking to them certainly as many
libertarians have integrity as people on
what is called a political left and I
always felt that even back in the city
college cafeteria I didn't think these
people were more than by their very
nature the enemy so there's considerable
overlap between traditional left
positions and traditional libertarian
positions right on war empire civil
liberties the Fed I know you talk a lot
about the Fed know my own view is we
should give I don't know I I don't know
that I ever was as idia logical as
you're suggesting you know what one
thing happens I did grow up in the Bronx
in the post-war period and everyone was
what you call left and Roosevelt was on
God and he was as far right as anyone
with would go I mean particular area
where I grew up so uh I do find those
ideas to be exhausted I I what I think
are important is you know what are your
basic values my basic value is that
every kid in America should have the
same right the Colin Powell had that I
had when we grew up in the Bronx we went
to good public schools method or is it
no no and I'm by the way I have kind of
view of Colin Powell than you do but but
if you read his autobiography it makes
him very clear points that what was done
for us at that time is first of all we
were valued no one ever suggested if you
grew up in our part of the bronx to
somehow you would throw away i think now
in this community here in Los Angeles we
think of many
people live in South Central LA area
right around USC and so close throw away
throw away they're not going to get at
the dinner table what other kids get
they're not going to go to the private
schools if they they're not going to go
to the good public schools in irvine or
someplace and basically we don't care
what happens around the seven is
embracing or so far that was not the
America I grew up in I always felt
valued and my parents were garment
workers they were immigrants and colin
powell in his book describes feeling
values okay and things worked for us the
after school program the city college
had free tuition free textbooks class
just before frita I was just inducted
into the city college communications
Hall of Fame so I had a chance to
schmooze with a lot of the old people
and we we all share that view of what
the school represented more public
education represent so I'll go to my
grave believing that we owe that to
every kid a decent public education are
you troubled at all by the fact that its
monopoly the monotony yeah I'm trouble
about plenty of things about education
as I say I'm troubled by the notion that
you're gonna have a massive school
district as you do in Los Angeles and
treat the whole areas of it is you know
then the throw away and we don't worry
about it you know we talked before my
son teaches in a you know inner-city
school in Oakland and I appreciate how
difficult that is you know how do you
find the parent or you know how do you
make this work how can the school solve
all the problems at the rest of the
society has failed but I'm getting back
to gut principle I believe I am against
privilege I am i'm against inherited
privilege i'm against the stacked deck I
want every I believe in the soul okay
maybe this goes back to ramparts
Catholic thing I believe that every
human being is entitled to an
opportunity to make the best of
themselves a real opportunity and that
involves state participation I by the
way if you're interested on much more in
favor of it being done locally I think
the states should be more of an
experimental incubator now that we've
got rid of segregation is a state issue
I am all for experimenting on many
shoes on the state level I think there
was wisdom to the founders there but in
terms of defining my own view yes I
think there should be equipped and by
the way internationally and I don't
think we should be messing around with
people and distorting their history
another principle i have having been a
journalist I don't like the fact that we
just blunder into other people's lives
here maybe I'm more of a libertarian I
yes so whether it's liberals or
Democrats or Republicans are
conservatives this idea that you can
just go bomb the heck out of people in
this somehow is going to improve their
life is there I think extremely
dangerous so I am much more I don't
consider myself an isolationist the
glasses Washington point out her in
despair well address he believes in
liberal intercourse with people believes
in caring about and believes in trade
exchange and so forth I'm not for
closing the walls but i do believe
people have to design their own heavens
and he'll in their own make their own
history and I I would wrote a column
today I'm very much opposed to this idea
that Muslims can't elect somebody that
they feel has good values to be the
president of Egypt yes I draw the line
when he takes away the rights of others
if he would do that but the idea you can
just over throw him because he happens
to believe in an ocean of God that you
don't accept seems to be quite dangerous
I think I think gut feelings are very
important actually and I unusual I'm an
academic and I'm not supposed to think
that but I actually agree with you on
that and I think that a lot of people on
the Left actually have sort of a genuine
affection for government they actually
really like government there's something
parental about the government and their
minds and I don't ever hear that coming
from you which is one of the things that
attractive about you for me and I just
sort of want to ask you what is your
what's your visceral reaction to to
government in itself I never liked them
and you know I well no no I mean I'll
tell you why what first of all I don't
have to go back to my childhood I've
traveled in totalitarian countries okay
I i I've experienced and of the left or
the right you know
quite early on i spent i tried to find
my mother's area in lithuania and it was
off limits and the interest tour and the
only way i could stay at that time and
in Vilna was to pretend to be drunk
white and pretend actually got drunk and
i ended up being in the drum tank and
all that this was I think 63 or 762 and
you know and I've been in a few jails
was in Algeria I was in the next you
know I've run afoul of people on I'm in
this country by the way it's no pleasure
when Ronald Reagan my big buddy was
governor I ended up in santa rita jail
for a night and that was you ask my
parents okay all right so you know I I
never liked authority and the Bronx
authority were desirous cops they were
quite brutal III didn't think they were
so wonderful I didn't think the
authority of the Mafia was so wonderful
either but at least they had better
music and prettier women but I I never
lied to arbitrary power I never did and
I resented a first well you know I was
in the new left I didn't like the old
left and and I mean I I was a beatnik
you know I'm an older guy I'm 77 I mean
I work to city lights books for three
years I loved you know the rebellion of
the beatniks and I I loved their whole
idea of not trusting any authority
that's not never been my issue I'm
afraid of you know unquestioned
authority that by the way I believe in
limited that is what makes you so
interesting and unusual especially on
the American Left where so many now our
praising government or excusing
government for spying on us for going to
war unnecessarily I want to stop right
there I want to thank Robert Scheer for
joining us today for reason TV I'm fed
Russell